what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so continuing our discussion on
Sinestro Corps war we get into the
superboy-prime one-shot now this is kind
of interesting and this is Tory of
course is written by Geoff Johns but
this looks like it was actually an
editorial slash legal mandate and it's
really kind of a funny situation because
during this time legal arguments began
to resurface between the Siegel and
Shuster families and DC because remember
they'd been suing DC repeatedly over the
idea over the rights to Superman and
Superboy but the idea was that because
superboy-prime was basically a spin-off
of the Superboy concept the idea was
that all properties routed to or based
off of the Superboy idea ultimately
belong to Siegel and Shuster and so what
ended up happening is DC actually had to
change the name because of the fact that
they had effectively kind of won this
lawsuit with regards to Superman all
things that were Superman related belong
to DC but with Superboy it was still in
contention and so what they effectively
did in this story is they used it as a
way to actually change superboy-prime
into Superman prong now in truth it's
really just a name change that's really
all it is that was the only thing that
was really necessary in order to pull
this off the problem is that in the
realm of comic books
you can't just simply change the name of
a character it wouldn't have made sense
for him just one day say you know what
I'm just going to start calling myself
Superman prong just because of the fact
that DC already had DC 1 million that
line of stories was already there and
the concept of Superman prime was
already in existence and so there had to
be an explanation that could
differentiate between superboy-prime now
calling himself Superman prime and
basically Superman 1 million as it was
kind of a cool idea in terms of how
that's unfolded but what this does is it
actually initially picks up with
superboy-prime as part of the Sinestro
Corps visiting the grave of Bart Allen
now this again is really just a
reflection of editorial mandates and the
reason why I say that is because Bart
Allen was a character who originally
appeared in 1994 and he was designed to
be this attempt to sort of reinvigorate
and keep I keep refreshing the idea of
the flash landscape remember after
crisis on Infinite Earths there was only
Wally West as the flash and then you
just kind of had newer members or I
guess the return of older members that
were gradually introduced as time went
on but Bart Allen was this descendant of
the flash family who basically sort of
just kind of aged at an accelerated rate
but the idea was to basically provide a
new iteration of the kid flash going by
the name
who could be an updated version of Wally
West when he was a kid before crisis on
Infinite Earths the problem with this
was that as time progresses I'm not
exactly sure why this was done as time
progressed DC began the idea of
basically removing his character and
this all basically goes back to the
introduction of a villain by the name of
inertia now inertia was basically
Thaddeus Thawne the second and the way
this worked out was that in the 30th
century in DC Comics Thaddeus Thawne was
a descendant of eobard thawne and the
idea was that Thaddeus Thawne had
basically become president and it
actually created a sort of hybrid clone
of Bart Allen and the original eobard
thawne combining their DNA to create a
singular being in the form of inertia
and what this did is it allowed for
inertia to operate as the arch enemy of
Bart Allen basically being his own
version of eobard thawne but again well
I'm not entirely sure about like the
sales or the the whole reason why this
was done all I really know is that DC
had come along and basically told the
writer at the time Marc Guggenheim that
he needed to eliminate Bart Allen and so
the story that was written to pull this
off was basically a story called flash
the fastest man alive and what basically
ended up happening here is inertia
developed a way to effectively strip
Bart Allen of his access to the Speed
Force basically making him normal at the
same time it also coincided with inertia
teaming up alongside the Rogues
and so because the Rogues are basically
the main enemy of the flash itself
according to editorial mandate this
story had to conclude with the Rogues
killing Bart Allen now again I don't
know this is really character
assassination I don't know if it was the
idea that DC just wanted to get rid of
him and truth as far as I'm aware it's
just speculation I'm sure there's some
source out there somewhere that explains
that but I haven't been able to find it
I haven't been able to find any
indication or any line-by-line
explanation of why BC chose to make this
choice but the fact remains that because
Bart Allen was one of the Flash's who
had originally defeated Superboy pond
during the events of Infinite Crisis it
created a sort of bitter anger a bitter
hatred between the two of them
especially because of the fact that
superboy-prime is terrified of
speedsters now the only indication of
his fear of speedsters really coming
takes the form of the idea that they
were able to push him into the Speed
Force not only that the speedsters
derive their power from the Speed Force
itself and so it's not like another
dimension I mean it is to a degree but
it's not it's not like pushing them into
a different universe it's not like
putting them on earth to or something
along those lines in the Speed Force all
time is kind
relative so for superboy-prime where he
was gone for like a day or an hour
something along those lines in the
speedforce he was there for years it was
effectively kind of like this living
prison where he can't access see or talk
to anybody the other half of this is the
motivation behind superboy-prime
remember he's a tragic character the way
that he was written in Infinite Crisis
made him a very sad character for those
of you guys who never saw my origin
video on him he basically came from
earth time it was part of this huge
multiverse that existed before the
events of crisis on Infinite Earths
an earth Prime in DC Comics is basically
the real world it's the world where
you're sitting watching this video right
now and so superboy-prime growing up in
this universe basically read comics
about superheroes he read comics about
Superman you know during the Golden Age
you know Superman as he appeared in DC
Comics it's one of those weird
meta-commentary kind of things but he
was basically hit with cosmic energies
with the energies of a comet and he
granted him powers that made him
equivalent to Superman the other half of
this was that because kryptonite didn't
exist in earth prime and because of the
fact that his reality of Earth Prime was
destroyed and the events leading up to
crisis on Infinite Earths superboy-prime
basically had no weaknesses aside from
red Sun radiation and even then his
strength level his endurance his speed
it was all well beyond the idea of any
of the Superman or superwoman who
existed at the time and so where he
basically was kind of shunted off to a
pocket universe after the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths and then
returned during Infinite Crisis of
course again we have those videos down
in our playlists about DC rebirth you're
welcome to check them out the idea here
was that he emerged as essentially a bad
guy because with him growing up and
reading superheroes as these beings to
look up to you and then seeing this new
earth continuity this post crisis on
Infinite Earths landscape coming
superheroes become darker a little more
gritty he basically came to believe that
the superheroes as they existed were not
real superheroes they were liars there
were frauds there were tricksters and so
the goal was that when he came out of
the Paradise dimension when he punched
reality and shattered it he ended up
just waging this war against all the
superheroes across the DC Universe and
literally crushing everybody I mean
there was a point where he faced off
against like 33 Green Lantern's and
killed them all it was absolutely insane
ultimately it took the efforts of the
original Golden Age Superman and the new
earth Superman to fly him through a red
son stripper above his powers and then
the Green Lanterns to encase him in this
giant green box one of the signs so they
have to basically keep him health but
remember during the events of I guess
part of the lead up to Sinestro Corps
war he was freed from this and he was
inducted into the Sinestro Corps proper
now the biggest issue about this little
tidbit of storytelling here is that he
still uses this modified suit that he
used during a Infinite Crisis that's
designed for the purpose or at least
seems to be designed for the purpose to
harness yellow energy now the problem
with this is that Geoff Johns kind of
gives us this weird scenario here when
superboy-prime used this mechanized
souter this powered suit during the
events of Infinite Crisis the goal was
to basically have the students serve as
a battery pack of sorts in the sense
that all Superman or all versions of
Superman's superwoman whatever the case
may be they act as a solar battery and
so their body basically absorbs solar
energy until it can't hold anymore and
once their body's supercharged once it's
fully charged the solar energy
they're as powerful as their as they're
ever going to be they've reached the
peak of their complete and total
potential what superboy-prime did in
developing his pack was basically give
himself additional solar energy which
means that he could fight longer and he
could fight harder than any of the
existing Superman that stood out there
this compound of the fact that he was
already stronger than any of the
supermen that existed out there so he
was basically a one-man army he was just
an absolute wrecking crew well of course
with this armor basically being
destroyed with him losing his powers
after being locked at a science cell and
then being freed by the Sinestro Corps
this suit is not exactly like the one he
wore before but it seems as though it
would serve the same the same purpose
the problem with this is that while he's
going against the combined efforts of
like the Titans and the Teen Titans and
all these different superheroes he keeps
making reference to the idea that he's
waiting for the Yellow Sun to come up
now again this is kind of a weird
scenario because historically speaking
in DC Comics the atmosphere of the earth
plays no part in the Yellow Sun in terms
of how it impacts a Superman whether
Superman is standing on earth or whether
he's floating out in space the impact of
Yellow Sun radiation is always the same
now the closer he gets to the Sun and
the longer he spends inside the Sun the
more powerful he'll become that's one of
the reasons why Superman one-million was
so powerful because he literally just
stayed inside of the Sun and so it
selves were just soaked with yellow sun
radiation with regards to this here it
basically looks like super white
mom's not nearly as powerful as he would
normally be but the idea is that if he's
not as powerful as he would normally be
why wouldn't he just go to the Yellow
Sun and then show up on earth fully
charged we don't have an answer to that
question instead we just kind of have to
go on the idea that he's not normally as
strong as he should be
but once the Yellow Sun comes up it
basically allows his energies to begin
recharging again now in truth drawing on
the nature of this story and what we're
seeing with him you know kind of
reflecting on his own life reflecting on
these moments that he's had you know
with regards to Laurie his girlfriend on
earth pond lamenting the idea of the
destruction of his own earth the idea
that he basically allied himself with
the Sinestro Corps just long enough to
allow the anti-monitor a moment of
victory so that he could stack it away
and kill him the implication seems to be
here that this suit maybe reduces his
powers or this suit perhaps blocks out
the Yellow Sun radiation to a degree or
it's just for the sake of storytelling
it's just for the sake of giving us a
chance to see him kind of talking about
these moments and to see him face off
against some of these super heroes
because remember if superboy-prime
suddenly showed back up on earth at the
same power level that he was before he
would have destroyed all these super
heroes without any questions they all
would have died and so the idea is that
once we have the arrival of care and
star of the Power Girl a super girl
basically of Earth - alongside Superman
and a super girl of the main DC Universe
this leads into the three of them trying
to best they can to hold off Superboy
pron now of course once the Sun comes up
his powers begin returning to him and
full force and he is completely
energized and so what this means is that
what little chance these superheroes had
to actually win is gone they basically
have no real chance anymore now in terms
of evolving him from superboy-prime into
Superman prime this comes by way of the
narrative that he's basically than
offering over the course of the story
because remember his whole life is the
idea that he's come to believe that
superheroes as they exist in DC Comics
at the time this story has been written
are not actually superheroes because in
the mind of superboy-prime there's no
moral ambiguity when it comes to
superheroes it's we're good guys they're
bad guys we fight them we arrest them
they go to jail done and done
that's it there's no sometimes it can
bend the rules sometimes we can break
the rules we hide things from our
friends that's not how Superboy pond
views superheroes give you superheroes
as being 100 percent in the right always
doing the right thing
no matter
circumstance now again doctoring that
infinite crisis line of stories that was
designed to be a meta commentary on
superheroes as they existed at the time
by geoff johns himself in a lot of ways
superboy-prime was geoff johns as he was
looking at the superhero world but the
overall idea here is that because
superboy-prime viewed these heroes as
morally ambiguous the goal was to
basically take the place of superman to
eliminate this version of Superman and
replace him and that's why he ends up
calling himself Superman crime because
there wasn't time in this history when
he was a superboy-prime but the reason
for that was because of the fact that he
had fought alongside the original 1940s
earth-2 Superman that was a Superman he
looked up to he had no desire to take
his place he had no reason to take his
place because that was a superhero that
superboy-prime idolized but with the
death of the original earth-2 Superman
with him being removed from the equation
now there's basically a place for
superboy-prime to say I am going to
become the real Superman as he should be
I'm going to become Superman as a hero
should actually be now we know just by
virtue of the evolution of his character
he's twisted he's basically lost his
mind but the fact still remains but
there was a lot of moral ambiguity when
it came to these heroes and so
ultimately he ends up just stripping off
the Sinestro Corps uniform which
coincides with the arrival of the
anti-monitor with the Green Lantern's so
on and so forth absolutely just dubs
himself
Superman Prime and so what this does is
this segues directly into the second
part of Sinestro Corps war when we
basically end up having Superman Prime
facing off against the ultimate weapon
of the of the Green Lantern's which of
course comes in the form of I on the
current host of the will power density
in the Green Lanterns of course this is
actually a guy named soda Miata it's
actually not Kyle Wayne because remember
Kyle Rayner is still part of the
Sinestro Corps but it sets up the entire
conflict and let me tell you something
like man superboy-prime in the second
half of Sinestro Corps war dude it is an
absolute massacre it's one of the
coolest things ever it puts the conflict
of Infinite Crisis to shame but it's one
of the craziest things because Infinite
Crisis picked on everybody right like
Mikey fought a ton of people there comes
a point where he ends up fighting like
all the superheroes and the Sinestro
Corps and the Green Lantern Corps all at
the same time and it is
it is one of the coolest parts of the
story Sinestro Corps war was so good it
was so awesome especially because of the
ending of how it all ends up coming to a
conclusion and what it's set for the
future of the Green Lantern landscape
anyway guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comment explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of a robb core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you all later please
[Music]